my name is Caitlin Caitlin Colton is for
you oh thank you now that I've popped
your cherry ladies were pretty
aggressive about the idea of your
virginity on the premiere do you think
that you being a virgin made the women
almost a little more sexual with you
that they wanted to talk to you about it
and get into that and and maybe take
your virginity yeah I think some women
obviously you know came right out and
said hey why let's talk about it would I
ever bring that up on a first date I
don't know probably not but I probably
knew that I was coming and I knew that I
was gonna have to talk about it at some
point did I think I was gonna have to
talk about as much as I did on night one
absolutely not
you know I really hope that throughout
all of this you get to see it different
sides of me than just the label of
urgent well I loved how you opened up
last night you said when you do have sex
for the first time you wanted it to be
tender and you also said you would have
had sex with Becca are you glad that you
didn't lose your virginity to Becca
looking back I mean everything happens
for a reason and I think I believe that
but then I also believe you make clear
and conscious decisions and where those
feelings were at I mean I just want to
make sure for me I want to be in love
and I want it to be meaningful
you know we've also heard about this
very revealing conversation that you
have with Caitlin Chris Harrison talked
about that when he revealed the women
and said it prompts reveals from her
from you what can you tell us about what
you reveal to Kayla in that moment um I
think this is just the understanding you
know while a lot of people make light
and including myself of my virginity
there is a deeper level to that that not
a lot of people know and I haven't spoke
about it publicly at all and I think in
that moment with Kaylin we had a safe
space with each other to share things
that we haven't really talked a lot
about and it'll give people a little
more insight not only to Who I am
to who she is and sort of how our
relationship was so a reason for that
virginity that people don't know yet
I mean yeah there's just like I've said
it before I we've been regards to my
virginity it's just so a lot of things
that go into it it's not a simple answer
people ask me the question knowing they
expect this boom this is why and I can't
give them that because that's not how it
is and I mean that's just the facts
people ask me about the virginity thing
are you sick of talking about it yet I
am yeah I just think it's really
important to to just break free of all
sorts of labels it would be the same
thing if you were like oh football
player it's like yeah I'm more than that
you know there's a lot of different
things dog-lover I mean I have much of
different titles that I like to hold on
to but I also have a lot more little
things that makes me into the person I
will people get an answer about it
during the season or are you still gonna
be addressing the virginity thing when
we're on after the final rose I mean I
hope so
stick to stick with us let's let's hope
that there's more to it than just the
reason anything but I do you know it's
not up for me to prove anything or to
have to defend it
but I think if people are looking for
more clarity on it or some more
background on it they're definitely
going to get that
[Music]